I'm good thank you yourself I'm doing
excellent like I was saying I have so
many questions and the problem is there
are so many things we can't talk about
yeah that must be for every for having
these you're in yeah pretty much yes
it's it's nonstop yeah non-stop not
talking you have no one stopped telling
you nothing right um I want to talk
about something you obviously can't talk
about which is so you find out how much
didn't I tell you about the full arc of
the story when he handed you the script
and how much is he saying read it and
let me know what you think pretty much
read it and let me know where you thank
me that that was split and ended that
with glass as well in fact I asked him
some questions before I read split and
he said just just read it and hold on
tight and you know try and keep an open
mind and get about him all right
and then when I read it I realized why
he said that I think he's you know he
trusts his material and he wants his
material to speak for him rather than if
you know if you've got to explain
everything away before somebody reads it
and you pray you've got a problem and
you're writing you know so no he was he
was pray he was pretty confident in his
ability to convey he won't need any
script you know without getting into it
there's a lot of stuff that goes on in
this movie especially in the third act
what was your reaction as you're reading
the script and it's all unfolding first
thing I was doing I was cutting
characters really and by the time I got
to about 20 or so choose I was like
already looking at my calendar go and
how long have I got
how long have I go I think I had three
months at that point two and a half
three months by the time I got the
script oh my god and then I read three
more and I went women and then stopped
at 23 and and this film and this edit
you see 20 in the original what we
originally that we actually performed 23
and there's 24 and I was like wait a
minute we're going 23 and we're leaving
1 oh you've got all that weight at the
top at the moment but you're starting
like 4 feet short I did the PK them up
what whatever and that we caught 3 hours
well we left three personalities behind
yeah he told me that the first cut was
three hours 20 minutes and that you know
there was a lot of deleted scenes
yeah the first cut of split I think was
about 3 hours 10 minutes Israel and he
tried to keep it that her first
and it was a long process of him like
shaving away and shaving away Lenny what
he ended up with on both movies he's
very very pleased that he shaved that
way but I think it's hard for directors
sometimes to especially a writer or
director perhaps yeah some of them no I
don't think some of them were quite free
and happy to let things go
on the day even and some of them were
very exact and precise about getting
exactly what they wrote and they want to
get everything that they wrote some
regulars actually have it in their
contract that you shoot everything they
wrote which can sometimes be tough night
doesn't ever um but yes is forgotten the
question now and I've rambled I've
rambled I have so many questions about
this but I have to ask use my last
question I'm so effing excited for it
chapter two yeah me too I cannot wait um
what can you tease people and what was
the shoot experience like the shoot
experience was great and great people
amazing director amazing cast the cast
incredible um it was pretty there was
days and I said what I'm just like this
is this is really disturbing you know
you don't you just can't look at the
other actors going like this is a great
gig and I'm really proud to be here
you're but this is really messed up you
know and a good way in a good way but
yeah I rarely get terrified by anything
you know but reading that book again as
an adult I wrote as a kid and it didn't
really mess with me as a kid better now
do it gave me nightmares
and what bailed us is just incredible
this this the commitment it's not just
me scary makeup and a funny voice
forever like the commitment in there 40
percent it is remarkable sure gotta go
up congrats you were effin awesome in
this thanks about you Susie
I can't we